i'm really excited to share with you
today i have a couple of different
stories around
weeds in terms of resistance mechanisms
and then we movements and how we can use
molecular biology and genomics to study
those
and then kind of finishing looking ahead
to you know what are some of the next
things we could be working on in the
area well let's jump in first of all
this is a photo uh we're at
fort collins or colorado state
university and it's an area where sugar
beets is kind of uh both historically
important for the region and then
recently well it still is a major crop
and here you can see a field that's full
of kosha closer to the tumbleweed if you
think of your old westerns you know
right before the showdown tumbles across
it's uh this one right here
and that is uh it's a big issue and the
herbicide resistance that we're studying
in that and other species is certainly a
major problem
we all know the critical challenges that
we're dealing with in terms of how do we
feed the world and close the world
sustainably and provide
all the plant services ornamentals
and things that we need so essentially
we know productivity needs to increase
and this needs to happen
with fewer inputs or less money spent on
inputs less water
clearing less land
all in the face of challenges from
climate change
shifts in species shifts in pest
problems supply chain issues
and so where do we fit into all of that
you know well they take away the yield
potential
of course you know uh from plant breeder
perspective
uh the
seed that you put in the ground has a
certain yield potential to start with
and then all the issues come along to
try to take away from that whether it's
stress drought
pathogens
insects
and weeds
this is a graph from a review paper kind
of looking at the different types of
loss potential that might happen due to
weeds pathogens viruses insects etc you
can see weeds are a big chunk of the
loft potential
but due to crop protection practices and
this includes everything so we're
thinking herbicides as well as your
management
uh you know cultural biological et
cetera
those actual losses are left but they're
still there they can typically be in the
range of you know five ten percent in a
lot of crops in different regions
and then what's the contribution of
pesticides to that there is a component
of it so thinking about how can we
you know better use the herbicide that
we have as well as those that may be
coming when we look at the herbicide
world market it's a really interesting
situation in that we have 26 modes of
action
but four of those you can see here
indicated in the darker colors four of
those make up more than 50 percent of
the herbicides that we use
and that's really pretty shocking one of
those this group 9
is glyphosate or roundup so more than 25
of global sales that one herbicide and
then within these three groups over here
there are a lot of different herbicides
within them but they all have the same
mode of action they're all working on
the same target site so there's
incredible selection pressure
if you take into account the next two
it's almost three quarters of herbicide
uses six modes of action
so you can see that results incredible
selection pressure and a lot of
resistance you can see we've got you
know nearly every herbicide site of
action has resistance
lots of different countries lots of
different crops so clearly both a global
issue and then depending wherever you
are you have very local issues
now what is resistance resistance is the
result of an evolutionary process when
we're putting the selection pressure on
weed populations with a lot of genetic
diversity you're selecting for any trait
that allows those plants to survive
and
in the world of resistance mechanisms
there are many different ways by which
this is possible we know that generally
resistant individuals are present
at a very low frequency
but then with repeated use of herbicides
they'll survive and they'll contribute
more privacy to the population
i always enjoyed this picture this is
one that the western took in 2011.
and what are you looking at here so this
is a this is a dry land system
you know this area eastern colorado
typically gets maybe 15 inches of rain a
year
so they'll alternate fallow and crop
cycle
during the fallow period in order to do
no-till or reduce till which of course
is building up soil carbon residue
soil health all these things
they don't do tillage they use
herbicides to control the weeds so
they've applied the herbicide glyphosate
or roundup out on this field and you can
see lots of dead this is kosha but this
one green streak is where one of those
tumbleweeds broke off and dropped off
all of its seeds
and then the next year they've come
through and sprayed you can see they're
all just this nice little track you can
imagine how it tumbled right across took
a little turn
even
some groups in canada have done research
where they put a gps tag on a tumbleweed
and let it go and they'll go for miles
and you know drop tens of thousands of
seeds as they go you can imagine then
how the population would grow from here
if you like say it again the next year
all of these will have a big advantage
and make lots of seeds so that is
resistance
another way to look at these kind of top
four or five mode of action groups when
i say mode of action just meaning kind
of the way the herbicide works and the
specific target it has in the plants
here you can see
the top five most herbicide
top five most used groups are the same
top five four cases of resistance so it
makes sense the more selection pressure
you have the more cases of resistance
are there
and you can see over the decades how you
know there have been different separate
spikes in resistance but you know more
recently the als and acca inhibitors
have increased in the 80s and then
roundup ready
crops and soybean and corn and cotton
in the 90s and 2000s
uh leading to you know kind of the spike
of glyphosate resistance
so it's a global issue
then it's not just resistance to single
herbicides it's resistance to multiple
herbicides within a population what
you're looking at here the data on wheat
species resistance of more than one and
so you can see there a whole lot that
have four five six you know up to 11
different modes of action within a
species
and then within a given site so this is
multiple herbicides within a population
you know two three four five different
modes of action within a population now
we do have some some populations even
resistant to six modes of action
species like the amarantha species
waterhemp palmer amaranth that are
dioecious there are many weeds that are
obligate outcrossers
so resistant straights can combine you
know they're they're crossing with each
other pollen can move quite a long ways
you know lynn you did that great work
with palmer amaranth measuring how far
it moves and uh not easy to do right but
um
you know gene flow in weeds even though
they don't get up and fly around you
know the the traits can still move and
combine
and this is an example of one population
with five different modes of action of
resistance yet actually no history of
24d use so just selection with a
different mode of action resulted in a
cross resistance to a different
herbicide
another issue is that for decades the
herbicide discovery industry has
regularly produced new active
ingredients new discoveries and you know
so
you know if you're thinking in the 70s
80s 90s there's something new coming out
every year
but a number of factors came together
that really have dropped off that
discovery rate
and we could have a conversation about
what those are but if you look at the
kind of this bold line right here these
are herbicides that are labeled
available and sold in the united states
in soybean and corn that could actually
control this weed palmer amaranth
and you can see that's up to
about nine here
and then this line is resistance so once
resistance is reported in the species
that's what gets you a data point right
here and notice how this line over the
last
you know say 15 years its slope is very
steep right and it's going to intersect
this line of discovery and development
quite soon
meaning they're essentially no effective
mode of action for that species anymore
so what do we do about that it's costing
around 350 million dollars typically to
discover and develop a herbicide
you know of course there's all kinds of
stuff going on with non-chemical smart
wheat control
but you know we've got to do better and
that's you know how can we think about
resistance from an integrated pest
management framework
people work on the economics and the
sociology knowing this is a so-called
wicked problem
and that it's just you know so many
factors go into why people make the
decisions that they make related to
management so
that's an incredibly important area
what do we do about it what action steps
do we take as you can see here
you know maybe we can continue to
discover a few more new modes of action
but we need non-chemical we need
emerging technologies
uh creative mixtures
and then what i want to talk the rest
about today is how genomics can inform
management so how can we use tools to
evaluate how well did we do with that
herbicide application can we identify
the species and can we monitor what's
going on out there
i'd like to tell you about
for this next section we'll talk about
resistance mechanisms and just to define
what do we mean by that the mechanism
itself can be any trait there are many
types of resistance traits to slow down
or reduce how much the herbicide gets to
the active site you know the the
herbicide is actually acting maybe in
the chloroplast or
at an enzyme in the cytoplasm wherever
it may be
so reducing how much of the herbicide
gets there or reducing how much activity
it has once it gets there so it's not
binding to its target side as well
we'll talk about a target site mutation
this could be a mutation in the gene
encoding that protein
so that it takes more of the herbicide
to knock out the activity of that
protein
that's what we call a target site
mutation we can also have increased
expression of that target site gene or
extra copies of it
the thing about these target site
mutations is that they are specific to
one mode of action group
you know the mutation in that gene
doesn't give resistance to a totally
different type of herbicide because as a
different target site
the other broad category of resistance
mutations is what's called non-target
site resistance
so these are all the things like
enhanced metabolism plants do have the
capacity to break down
uh xenobiotic compounds from the outside
you know certainly has evolved over the
years for defense against herbivores
and
you know all the different things the
plant might encounter some of those
happen to metabolize herbicides plants
also are incredible biochemical
factories sometimes the herbicide
molecule has a similar structure as
maybe a synthesis pathway
you can have alteration in how the
herbicide moves around and it can get
stored into a vacuole or some place
where it won't have activity
reduction in how much is taken up and
then i'll show you one example of a
rapid necrosis or rapid cell death
essentially the leaves respond so
clearly the herbicide and dye that the
herbicide doesn't move around anymore
this mechanism of enhanced metabolism is
probably one of the most difficult to
deal with from the perspective that it
can give you this potential for cross
resistance so
selection with one herbicide in the past
might give you already those plants
might be resistant to the herbicide ud's
next maybe even to the herbicide that
hasn't even been discovered yet because
of the you know the shared chemical
features
that's the the really vexing one
so i'll tell you a couple of specific
examples now first of all is the
synthetic auxins these are called group
four within the herbicide classification
and these are include some of the oldest
herbicides and some of the newest
there's still ongoing herbicide
discovery in this area q4d was you know
discovered and synthesized in the 40s
and really you know introduces the first
synthetic
chemical herbicide in the late 40s and
50s
and what these herbicides do is they
mimic auxin or indole acetic acid the
plant hormone controlling
you know so much about cell division
cell growth
so you can see the structures of one
called that gamba and one called 24d
these are herbicides have been used for
years they're selective
between grasses and dicots for the most
part so you would traditionally use
these in corn
in cereal like wheat and barley to
control broadly weeds
however
from transgenic trait perspective you
have things like roundup ready extend so
they have a metabolism gene to break
down dicamba
or enlist
has a transgenic gene to metabolize 24d
so now you can make
soybean which is normally very sensitive
to both these herbicides resistant to
dicamba and 24d this thereby expands the
use of these herbicides and
so there are concerns
well certainly especially dicamba around
their off-target movement but for the
potential for resistance when you have
older herbicides and now you're kind of
suddenly expanding in use
here this also gives you a picture of
just how much these are used uh you can
see 24d at the bottom there's a bit old
data now from 2014
but you know over 160 million hectares
of 24d use followed by the canba
this definitely needs to be updated now
with the
whole commercialization of these crops
so i'm sure somebody can crack that down
this graph is from weedscience.org so if
you're ever interested in kind of this
current status of herbicide resistance
you can go there this is the survey web
page i've just pointed out these are all
the species resistant to group four
herbicides sometimes
people
kind of say you know for synthetic
oxygen herbicides we don't see as much
resistance and it is true that the pace
has been kind of slower when you
consider these herbicides
first used here in the 50s you know a
couple of cases but for the most part
you know
maybe we're seeing more resistance
recently
when you look at the mechanisms there
are now a few of these that we know so
these orange ones are showing target
site
the blue one is a case of metabolism and
some of them remain unknown so i'm going
to show you one example of a target site
and one example of metabolism for
synthetic oxygen
to say a little bit about the mode of
action
you know certainly it is complicated but
what i want you to understand just for
the purpose of today
is that auxins act by
kind of releasing inhibitors of
transcription
so there are lots of genes controlling
uh cell growth that are kind of to have
a transcription factor on the gene ready
to go to turn it on and then there's a
repressor on top of that called an oxia
protein
so that's uh that's what's shown right
here in step one this is the the dna
the promoter in front of the gene uh
this one for example is ncd that leads
to the synthesis of aba
abscissic acid and there are others you
know leading to the synthesis of
ethylene
and a number of different things get
turned on by oxen so under normal
conditions just a little bit of oxygen
in the cell this gets degraded right
here you can see this whole complex
called tier 1 comes in and auxin is kind
of the glue binding those together so it
will take it away and degrade it
then that releases this transcription
factor to turn on the gene
normally what happens is that very
carefully regulated when you now can
insert a huge amount of synthetic oxygen
all of this oxide repressor gets taken
away
genes like nce gets turned on you get
sudden synthesis of other hormones
that's citric acid ethylene
and the plant just kind of grows out of
control
and
that's essentially how oxygen herbicides
work and then you get fan then
so this target site right here this
oxide these are
really fascinating gene family plants
generally have 20 or 25 different genes
and so they kind of have different
functions somewhat redundant somewhat
specific and i yeah i think
from herbicide resistance perspective we
have a lot more to learn about these
but the case of target site resistance i
want to tell you about is in this
mustard species it's called cesimbrium
orientale
what you're looking at here this is from
adelaide and south australia
the resistant plants on top this is
showing number of days after treatment
with a
somewhat
regular dose of 248 250 grams per
hectare through the resistant plants
really don't show much epinasty
epinasty is the stem twisting and leaf
curling that happens when these
herbicides are applied
whereas the substituted plants this is
very typical you can see it two days
three days notice how twisty this is
getting and the plant will eventually
die
so these plants appear like they're kind
of just not perceiving
the 24d very much you know they have a
very different response
so the first thing i had this is an
example of you know sometimes science
takes a while uh anita cooper started in
2014 and graduated in 2018
and then another student picked up the
project but right at the end of hers we
used an rna-seq approach on
f3 recombinant inbred lines so we made a
cross
i got f2s and self-pollinated those
and what we discovered in this gene it's
called ia2
the resistant planes all have this kind
of gap in coverage what you're looking
at here is the illumina reads aligned to
the this gene sequence notice how
susceptible has
the gray area represents read coverage
and there's a total gap right here
we noticed that that okay this seems
worth following up on
and then the next students work on it
marcelo figuereto
he uh then confirmed that yes in fact
there's a deletion so check out this is
the gene sequence right here of ia2 what
it normally looks like and then there
are 27 nucleotides that are deleted in
the resistant allele nine amino acids
but it stays in frame it doesn't break
the protein
it's in a region called the dagron tail
why is that important
the dagron this is a well characterized
region with this gw ppv sequence
that's where oxen actually binds so if
you mutate in particular this glycine
that gives resistance but it also has a
trade-off and that it doesn't bind to
oxygen as well either
this one is quite interesting so there's
bigger entails in between these two
domains
and what it turns out you can see here
in modeling this that it obviously makes
the protein shorter there's less
distance between the dagron and what's
called the pbi domain or the mean three
then in the three dimensional model we
worked with front eon on this what you
can see here
so this little part that dips down the
bottom protein is tier one and this
little part going down is binding with
24d right here and what happens once
that binds the herbicide kind of sorry
the oxide protein is able to kind of
embrace tier one i almost think like a
hug
so the the degrom is here and the pb1
domain has to get to the other side
and that's what allows the
ubiquitination to happen for it to be
degraded
in the case of the resistance these two
things can't bind at the same time
there's not enough room so either the
dagron combined
or the pb1i domain combined but not both
at the same time or just much less
efficiently they tend to fall apart
so this is why the resistance works the
24d
can't get this protein degraded anymore
but it still has all of its parts to
stay on the dna and be a repressor so
when 24d comes in
all these genes are no longer
bonding
and as you might expect when you
overexpress this it appears to have a
big effect on the phenotype so this is
in arabidopsis we you know clone the
gene and then do a transgene into a
rabidopsis
so here you can see
this plant is expressing the wild type
of ih2 so over expressing that no big
deal for the growth
when they're heterozygous as well maybe
not too much in effect but these are
homozygous lines for the mutation and
they're just they don't grow very fast
they make very little feed
in fact it's hard to work with
experimentally we can barely get enough
seed of these to keep the line alive
so clearly over expressing it is bad
because then auxin itself is not able to
signal the regular growth and
development
here you can see the data is showing how
that this mutation does give resistance
uh so these are the same arabidopsis
lines you can see at the top that uh
with the two resistant events are still
growing when they're on c4d and that
canva
as well they're
kind of maybe a bit sensitive to oxen
itself but not as much and then the
susceptible ones you can see their
growth is completely inhibited by 240
and uh
and what's interesting is this mutation
it also gives resistance to two dicamba
so within this group of herbicides
supporting that came out of a different
structure they're considered a different
chemical family
and that is uh
kind of an interesting thing to know
that this mutation gives resistance to
both 240 answered that gamba and we
found a number of other synthetic
oxygens that it also gives resistance to
so there's more to understand about that
specific molecular binding
then i mentioned you know overexpressing
the transgene is negative however
here we have f5 in red lines so they're
either homozygous for the resistant
mutation or homozygous for susceptible
the rest of their genetic background has
been kind of recombined
so that we're not comparing two very
different genotypes
and you can see they have essentially
the same seed production they have the
same growth curve
so we don't see evidence of a fitness
cost for this allele
in when it's under its native promoter
and so i think that's what's also
important
is see this gene appears to be kind of a
stress responsive gene it's really not
expressed much normally
so you know there's just a lot more
dynamics here to understand but very
interesting that
that this uh mutation when it's again
native promoter these are not stress
plants you know they're not under
competition or anything but it doesn't
appear to have much of a negative effect
then finally this is the model that
marcelo put together to to kind of show
and it's just what i've talked to here
you can see it a bit better you see how
the dayground comes in and it binds
there and then this pbi domain can reach
across
whereas when you have this little part
in between is just that much shorter the
dayground combined but the pbi can't and
you keep
repression of transcription
interestingly you could make this
mutation in crops if they have a homolog
of this gene you do gene editing and
take out part of that diground tail
and uh so yeah this was pretty exciting
work where i think
now we have with this inside in terms of
the oxide beams to start looking at
other examples of 240 resistance etc we
may look at those target sites
i think about non-targets i mentioned
rapid necrosis this is some work that a
sandwich phd student from rio de janeiro
did uh just philiology came to
uh our lab at colorado state and worked
for a year this is caniza sumatrinsis
that's resistant to 24d
as you know 24d is kind of fairly fast
acting but this is what several plants
typically look like again you have
epinasty twisting but these resistant
plants if you can see it on the screen
these leaves are totally dead the older
leaves at 24 hours this is 48 hours
after application but you see it
you see them start to really darken and
look water soaked within hours so
somehow the plants are
receiving 24d and triggering a rapid
cell death pathway
this is one that we're kind of trying to
take a genetic mapping approach to to
see if we can figure out but um very
fascinatingly fun
the second story i want to tell you
about is from
again marcelo figueredo so he's working
on support knee resistance and water
hinge amaranthus tuberculotis
and in this case this is a the type of
enhanced metabolism
so this was a water head that was it
evolved in nebraska in a seed production
field so grass speeds and they're using
214 year after year
these are the the known metabolic
pathways for 240 so and this is the same
for oxen actually
in in plants there's a conjugation by
this enzyme dht
to uh typically to some amino acids or
sometimes to sugar
and or amino acids followed by the sugar
and that's reversible so this is the way
the the plant can store oxygen have it
ready to go but kind of inactive and
then cleave that amino acid so it's very
available
a way to inactivate it however is with
an oxidation reaction so here you can
see
um
a lot of times they see this in monocots
and brasses that are resistant to people
use they'll metabolize the ring
hydroxylate it and that inactivates its
activity as an oxygen
so looking at waterhemp first thing to
point out is that it does have a rather
different response
see how they do show epinases the
resistant plants are on the bottom at
500 grams per hectare so a little bit
higher dose than the other one
notice how they do twist the stem really
bends
and then after four or five days they
start straightening back out the plant
does kind of retain this bend in its
stem the rest of its life you know that
damage is done
but it's able to recover whereas the
sensitive plants very very sensitive you
know they just fall over and they're
twisting and
they're done
so that is
now you know kind of looking at other
examples of auxin herbicides you can
kind of ask are they showing epinasty or
not in that
perhaps you might ask if this plant is
perceiving oxen right oxygen is doing
some of its things and then it's able to
recover after a while
and that then is kind of consistent with
this idea of enhanced metabolism on the
left where you're looking at is
the
hplc chromatographs from
radioactive labeled 214d molecule
so in the sensitive plants you have the
240 peak and basically one main
metabolite heat
and in resistant plants you have a much
smaller 240 feet and three distinct
including that first one but that one's
much smaller
now on the right here you're looking at
the degradation of 24d in the plant over
time
basically you see that the resistant
plants are metabolizing it um
five times faster than successful or you
know so they're clearing 24d out of
their system
and then to
further go on marcelo did this work to
identify what these metabolites were so
we purified them off the column and went
to the nmr and the mass spec and got all
this data so the metabolite one here
what
is going on is it's being conjugated
to an aspartic acid
and that's that's what metabolite one
here is but that's reversible that's
still essentially available for d
but in the resistant planets in red
what's happening is you're getting the
hydroxylation at the five
carbon position
and then we don't even actually see that
that metabolite is very labile or i
think this is just a very reactive group
because right away what happens is a
glucose gets added
and then uh malonyl is added to that
glucose so now this is totally well i'll
show you the data but this is inactive
and it's going to be incorporated into
you know cell wall or vacuum and it's
not reversible
we
ran the experiment with malathion so
malathion is an insecticide but it also
included some cytochrome p450s in the
plant
and what you can see in the data here is
that resistant plants without malathion
you know they're surviving very well
but when you add melathon they
essentially start to look like
susceptible so you're if you're able to
knock out this metabolism
and revert to susceptibility so it
suggests they don't have a target
signification
then this data
you know sometimes i have to acknowledge
the people who are in the lab doing all
the work because marcelo
probably spent more than a year to
synthesize these molecules especially
this one right here
and um
just an incredible amount of work but
then what he was able to do is he took a
rabid office and grew them on aggro with
these different compounds so 24d itself
you know
highly
high biological activity you can see
it's a i75 of 0.012 micromolar
but then for the aspartic acid this is
the reversible one it loses a lot of
auxin activity it's 100 fold less
active than 240 itself
then this hydroxylated one
completely knocked out right
what 20 000 times less oxygen activity
so you really
you know you have to be 100 micro moles
compared to 0.01
uh to start to have some oxygen activity
from that one
and then you also have this school
system where we've got a there's a gas
reporter that's linked to a oxygen
responsive gene
in arabidopsis so with that tool he's
able to show you know 240 at 0.01 and
0.1 you see how you're getting this blue
color that shows you auxin signaling
happening with aspartic acid you know
you have to go to higher concentrations
and with the 5-hydroxylated you see even
at 100 micromolar you're not getting any
blue color so it shows that these
metabolites are formed very rapidly in
the resistant plants and they've lost
their biological activities
we worked with pat channel and darcy
jacqueline to try to map these genes
and what we got to was on chromosome 4
there are some cytochrome p450s on one
arm of that
chromosome and one of them is called sip
81e
and all the mapping kind of points so
here you can see in some expression data
that it's you know kind of
four fold higher in resistance
actually i think
well this this uh tree as well this is
the one that really has a big difference
see it's four times higher and resistant
than s untreated
it is induced in both r and f
so we're looking at all these so far we
haven't been able to show that any of
these three
actually metabolize 24d in a different
heterologous system but we're still
working on it it may just be something
with with the expression
we're using a yeast expression system as
one of the main tests
so there's there's more to understand
but we think it could be this uh 81ed
then what's you know current situation
this is palmer amaranth again
from larry steckel and tennessee
where you know they're using this uh
extend soybean with that camber
resistance and so here you can see the
the field dose is kind of here 280 grams
per hectare
and they're surviving that and surviving
up to
two and three times that that dose so
now the question will be is this
metabolism is it target side is a
combination is it something else
uh again so much to understand about
auxin resistance so that's where
we need to understand more about these
cross resistance patterns from the
target side beams
understand more about the interaction
with the target site
than thinking about metabolism how is
that working
um
you know for to some extent we're not
really seeing the cross resistance from
metabolism in this case but
again more to understand and then of
course the rapid response
we definitely need we genomes to study
this so we're working with gene families
and trying to map
if we think about the increasing use of
dicamba in 240 this is just going to
continue to be very critical both for
management and
understanding
the next i like to talk about how weeds
move around and how can we identify them
better
and be more informed about about what's
happening
and this is the
venus amaranthus so you'll be familiar
with a lot of these things like
tuberculotis or waterhemp retroflexus
rhetori
includes palmer amaranth
photos here as they start to flower you
can identify them but at the ceiling
stage it's incredibly difficult
and what's even more difficult is that
the seed stage you know so here's the
siege of four different species
and if you're if you have a whole pile
of them maybe you can kind of
differentiate them
but if you have one or two
virtually no chance and so the issue in
the ag industry recently has been that
some of these species are very common
around north america
some of them such as palmer amaranth are
kind of expanding their range
and some states including minnesota iowa
ohio have listed palmer amaranth is a
prohibited not just weed
so seed analysts will be looking at for
example pollinator mixes or things for
conservation reserve planting you know
kind of species
and they'll look at the
do this analysis they can identify it to
amaranthus to the genus they'll put that
on the seed tag
now it can't be sold in those states
without restriction but if you don't
know if it's palmer amaranth or not
we had a collaboration with the
university of minnesota
and we developed some genetic markers
using what's called the cast so these
are
basically a single nucleotide or
you know genetic variant genotyping
competitive assay
very nice because it's fast it's high
throughput it's cheap and we develop
three different markers
we're able to extract dna from a single
seed and say yes or no with a palmer
amaranth or not
we can also take a mixture of up to 200
seeds with containing just one palmer
amaranth and detective that's what this
data is showing down here in orange is
uh kind of the signal that you get for
100 palmer amaranth
compared to water hem so the signal is
up here for water hamping everything in
between down to as low as a half percent
or one in two hundred
and then a couple photos just to point
out this is uh one that a friend of mine
littard lawrence who now works at bayer
took to 2009
the back of a cotton picker
and so you can imagine how much
weed seed is ending up on there if the
plants can actually grow on it this is
still driving around and thinking
so you know these weeds do move and this
equipment gets bought and sold including
internationally so just from the
perspective of hygiene and preventing
weed seed introduction
and then this is the concerning one i
know you know here in new york state you
have a few populations of palmer
amaranth and this is uh in oregon where
until now the pacific northwest palmer
amaranth has not been there
but joel felix recently sent this photo
around a group of uh weed scientists and
he sent out some leaves from these
plants and were able to confirm that it
was in fact palmer amaranth although
it's pretty easy for the photo to sell
too
now also thinking further about movement
i wanted to share this story so palmer
imran is
an invasive weed in south america it's
been in the records known in argentina
since the 80s but it was never
documented in brazil or uruguay until uh
maybe 2015 or so
and so paul need who is at rothamsted in
the
got some funding for this project and we
worked with uh aldo morado in brazil
alejandro garcia and uruguay and martin
villarreal and argentina
got samples from this country
and then did
you know genotype by sequencing got you
know just kind of markers across the
genome
and asked questions about how related
they were to each other how related they
were to populations in the us
as well as whether or not they had the
marker that we have for glyphosate
resistance which is increase of the
target side gene there's a duplication
for uh the targets
yes
so what we found is that there's pretty
strong evidence for separate
introductions into argentina and brazil
which you know we kind of knew that from
the historical records that the data
confirmed it
potentially
depending on how you look at the data
you might argue that there is a separate
introduction to uruguay or perhaps
a similar one from brazil that moved
around
these are the
plots from structure analysis so the
analysis supported a k of three
or you know three different groups the
one of eight is also kind of interesting
i thought this was so you looked at
colorado this is just one that we had in
eastern colorado and um
appears to have some similarities to
that one in argentina so i promise i
never brought anything there but um
you know these we did and also you can
look the data as kind of population
trees uh you know phylogeny et cetera
and
a couple of things to point out you
notice in in argentina there are a
couple of populations that have these
blue bars as well as this you know
some genetic similarities to the other
population
so we also check these markers for the
extra chromosomal circular dna
and the increased etf and that's what we
found that
brazil and uruguay
have this increased epsus copy number
and those populations brazilian wave
this marker is for that extra
chromosomal circular dna that carries
the duplication
so they have it the ones in argentina
don't but when we looked at this
population right here there actually
were a couple individuals that had it so
that suggests there was some movement
it's a little bit from brazil
down to argentina
so again i just showed this combine
example because
for brazil at least they think somebody
bought some machinery from the u.s and
it may have brought the wheat team along
with it
unfortunately in those kind of data sets
it's hard to really resolve you know to
do the forensic of what actually
happened
bottom line there's a ton of genetic
diversity for sure even in these
introduced populations
now kosha again here's another photo of
one of the sugar beet fields in colorado
with lots of kosher close to the
tumbleweed you can see across a region
here something that we'll do is uh kosha
also has a deduplication in that case
it's a tandem duplication
we have markers for it and uh growers
crop consultants can send in kosher
samples and we'll run that in the lab
and say yes you have increased copy
number you have glyphosate resistance or
no you don't
and so this is an example of a map
across the region of a bunch of
populations
but we did some work with you know we
had samples from alberta montana through
to northern texas
and within this um eric patterson the
phd student who works with me is now at
michigan state
and he did the sequencing to construct
that a mobile genetic element and i love
this we have the the poster of barbara
mcclincock back there on the wall they
talked about transposons so
it appears at least in the in the
resistant genotypes there's a mobile
genetic element that is present next to
epfcs and then there's the tongue
uh
there's one version of it that's about
30kb and another one that's 56kb
containing several genes right next to
it
and so we'll just call that genotype a
that's kind of our central great plains
one
and that's the one that we worked in
first but then we found that from the
northern great plains we found what we
call genotype b
they have the increased copy number
they have an increase you know more
copies of that mobile genetic element
but they don't have
we call this the type 1 and type 2
repeat we made some markers for that
they don't have that so it kind of
suggests that may have evolved
independently
or at least it's pretty divergent from
the one in the zebra bay plains
and then here in oregon in idaho there's
even a third kind of genotype that
does not have an increase in that
particular mobile genetic element
so we think that you know
we could probably conclude that
glycerate resistance has evolved at
least two perhaps three times
independently and we also have a lot of
movement you'll notice that we can find
genotype b and c
here we can find genotype a up here so
there's definitely evidence of that
movement so how can we understand across
the continent how we've been moving
around and potentially disrupt that
would be important
now i want to finish up the kind of
final chapter of the talk is to think
about you know what's next how do we
move beyond trades or beyond the things
we're doing
and of course here and
many places great works going on for
cover crop and precision
work robotics and harvest weed seed
control eric westra has been a research
scientist working at csu for several
years we've done some chaff lining work
in the in wheat and of course smart
sprayers that can detect weeds from
crops
so in the context of all of that
uh the project area that i'm working on
right now is
what you might call rna targeting you
know using that spray on gene silencing
method
there's a lot in the space around rnai
you know so specifically using uh some
kind of double strand rna or sir me
or particularly for insect management
and diseases so you know insects are
great they actually chew on things and
eat them so you can get them to take up
a gene silencing target the problem for
plants is we've got to get it to absorb
through the cuticle the cell wall
everything
so these are just you know some examples
of startup companies and lab groups
working on that what i'm working on is
with a startup company in philadelphia
it's called ohm life tech and dino hyu
is the ceo there and we have some darpa
funding to work on this and so what
these are they're something called
antisynth oligonucleotides
so a similar concept of gene silencing
but a little different pathway rather
than risk and dicer and argonauts of uh
you know the fi rna
what happens here is these
antisynthologicals will actually bind to
the mrna
and the ones we're using they recruit
ribonuclease h which cleaves the rna
and then that block their your target
trigger can be reused again to silence
another rna
now these antisynthologicals they've
been approved by the fda four different
drugs listed here
and then there's a ton of research and
that's mostly what venus company is
working on is cancer and hiv
why does all that matter well these
things are very stable and uh the
version the venus company is working on
is what's called the third generation
so it has a fluorine on the
sugar which makes it very resistant to
degradation so it's stable at room
temperature stable and water i think it
has potential to actually be stable in a
in a jug and storage and you know used
with dirty water and everything so
it's called phantoms
again this is just a comparison of the
of the anticipator pathway to
sir rna
and what we're working on is how can we
be delivered so they have very good
uptake into a single cells but with
plants you know there's still some
challenges we have a fluorescence marker
so we can treat roots treat leaves and
see that yes these oligos are getting in
but they're kind of just not that
consistent here's some mrna data so you
targeting three different genes in the
plant
you can see kind of the control
treatment scramble is an algo that
doesn't target anything
and we can knock the expression of these
genes way down for a period of time
but it's inconsistent and i can say you
know there are times when you try the
same experiment the same way and it
doesn't work we need to improve how much
is getting in
so for that that's where the this new
project comes in katie martin is a
postdoc sheet computer phd at uc davis
has a chemistry background
what we're working on is nanoparticles
and when you look at the literature in
this area a lot of work with
nanoparticles with rnai whether si rna
or double strand rna it just gives them
a certain shape or affects their charge
so that they're better able to get into
a cell
and where
our objective is to try these
nanoparticles and see if something
improve the uptake of these particular
oligos
into the nucleus so we have different
ways we have fluorescence assays elusive
race athlete
and we'll be trying to then eventually
want to move into palmer amaranth and
start testing different gene targets
uh but you know it's i'm really excited
about this and i i feel like it can open
up an area where where you know can have
something that can be very safe from
environmental and toxicology perspective
from applicator perspective
and also very custom tailored in terms
of you know crop safety
adaptable the new weed issues as things
come along
but again we'll need all the weak
genomes and information to do this so
the final thing i want to share with you
is about the international weed genomics
proportion which is a public private
partnership involving a lot of
institutions
the study we genomes and
really when you
step back and one of the things i love
thinking about weeds all the time is
that
what is better adapted to our cropping
systems than we you know they're there
and they're thriving despite everything
we're doing for thousands of years to
try to get rid of them this is a picture
of kosha again
uh this is a c4 warm season plant that
flowers in the hottest part of the
summer but it also germinates
very very early in the like late winter
so it's able to survive froth
temperatures um really cold
you don't see that very often with the
first deport so you know could we find
genetic traits from weeds to help
improve crops you know make them more
stress tolerant for example
again we'll need weakness so what we
have you can go to wegenomics.org the
website up now
and we have three objectives to actually
sequence and annotate these new genomes
which as you know if you're working in
any kind of non-model species that's
been a challenge so with the industry
funding we can see the four companies
here sponsoring it with some matching
funding from the foundation for food and
ag research we're able to generate this
resource then we'll we have it up we
have a website we have online analysis
tools
so everyone you can sign up for this and
and then to kind of have the research
coordination get people talking together
what ideas do you have what resources
and hopefully to just drive those
discoveries and new things coming out
and get more people trained and working
in lead science here you can see again
this is eric patterson so he developed
the annotation pipeline or you know
using existing tools but also with uh
the pac bio isostate data for the rna
and this is just i love looking at this
list you can see here 21 different
species for which we have what called
platinum level chromosomes some of these
are telomere telomere assemblies of
weeds
and
for the outcrossing weeds we're actually
assembling both haplotypes now
we get kind of a two for one
and you can see things like uh you know
so actually canada this is our the first
kind of
bespoke weed genome you know done for
that purpose done by ag canada in 2020
so two years ago and now all the recipes
have been done
and uh hopefully some species that would
be of interest for you and in the area
and this is just going to continue to
grow we're thinking by the end of next
year we'll probably have over 40 you
know
one example i want to share i guess if
you can't see this at the top this is
for basketball terrier or moth mullen
and what's cool about this so you
probably from or maybe
some of you may not be but the beel seed
experiment in michigan state so uh this
botanist in the 1800s buried these seed
bottles of seeds right
and uh every 10 or 20 years they dig
them up and see what germinates over
basketball terri is still germinates
and uh so this last round they dug it up
last fall
germinated over 140 years old and so we
were able to get the tissue samples from
that plant and sequence it and that this
was just uh
i think on the ninth we got these
results from uh corteva where they're
doing the work
14 chromosomes uh three of them are
gapless so that's telomere to telomere
and no gaps in the in scaffold so one
scaffold per
chromosome now talk about you know uh
possibilities to study dormancy and you
know seed bank biology
uh just you know really really excited
for this one
also want to share with you that there
will be a second genomics conference
coming up with the wheat sign society
meeting in january so this is the kind
of the monday before there's going to be
a data hackathon and some keynote
speakers and no registration costs
we'll also have some funding for early
career researchers so if you're a grad
student postdoc you apply to that and
then you know tack on the the wssa
meeting afterwards
so with that i'd like to say thanks for
your attention and be happy to take
questions i want to thank uh you know
funding particularly for herbicide
resistance a lot of the crop protection
companies
fund that research as well as some from
usda and the darpa grant for for rna
targeting then of course all the great
people graduate students and my
colleague frank dion at csu and other
research partners for
all the work and again it's been just a
wonderful opportunity to be here had
some great conversations so far and i'm
really looking forward to the rest of
the game
thanks
questions
geneva anybody
yes
they
illegal
are a uh our uh targeting work our
targeting work
um
getting the
uh illegal through each surface is very
difficult
have you ever thought of uh
spray the omega
kind of look
with the hope that it can get through
into the pond
because when pollen germinate
thursday core
where there's no cell wall
so the illegal can go deep very easily
actually we did quite a bit of work with
um
illegal antisense or legal transfection
really
okay
yeah so for everyone online the question
was around you know the challenge of
getting oligonucleotides into a plant
and that uh pollen cells
is particularly during that pollen
germination have an opportunity where
there's no cell wall
and that's a really intriguing idea yeah
because um
you can take the angle of you know let's
try to control weeds at the early stage
but maybe you know you have some weeds
or they're already there could you stop
them from setting seed right so maybe
you could silence something critical for
embryogenesis uh
that's a that's a very interesting idea
yeah
and so much of you know you're thinking
of ecologically based weed management
and the seed bank you know could you
you want to run down the c bank if you
can stop that big deposit somehow uh or
have another another opportunity i think
i'll definitely follow up on that
suggestion
thanks
so we have one on the chat here um from
uh brian brown um exciting results if
successful will the fana aso kill weeds
outright or make plants susceptible to
herbicides again
and is it species specific
yes um
so the different parts of that question
the fan asl would be very species
specific yeah and that that will be kind
of a challenge if you say okay in this
field we have five different species you
have to have and i'll go for each one
because they they work on
you know base pairing rules and they
have to be an exact match they're
usually you know 22 25 bases long
so you would be you know needing to
design and develop this for each species
that you're after
and then the other question could they
be kind of outright kill plans or would
it
uh it would sort of have both options
we're definitely looking at could they
you know kind of kill plants on their
own or can you kind of if you understand
resistance mechanisms could you knock
those down enough that the herbicide
would work again
that was uh
roughly
10 years ago or so now
monsanto had a lot of presentations
around rnai approach but they are
knocking down epsvs and plumber imran to
get glyphosate to work again but you'll
notice i mean we don't have a product
like that now they cut it because i
think the challenges of stability of
that uh you know double strand our new
approach but i think there's there's
really potential for both
in some ways kind of maybe getting
existing herbicides to work again on
resistance as you get a little bit
lower threshold to jump over perhaps
than stand-alone herbicide
yeah
yeah one of the things that you
mentioned was how
when
for some of these resistance mechanisms
there could be a little bit of selection
uh against and so like for wildlife
versus
herbicide resistance
i was wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about some of the how
that made bearing by
some of the mechanisms of resistance
that you encounter
definitely so the question is is kind of
around fitness costs of resistance
mutations or you know does a resistance
mutation
would it be can it be selected against
in the absence of the herbicide
so we have examples that range from
major fitness penalty to net at all i
think some of the very first examples of
herbicide resistance are to the
photosystem ii inhibiting herbicides and
they're
a target site mutation in that complex
so they have a huge tradeoff so the
mutations make plants resistant to the
herbicide
but they
do photosynthesis much slower so they're
they grow slowly they make less seed
and we can definitely see in cases where
when the main herbicides is atrazine
and
kind of from surveying across the
midwest there used to be a lot of
atrazine resistance for uh for with this
target side mutation
and then atrazine didn't get used as
much for a long time especially the
shift around the body and of course for
other reasons but then
now you see when you find actual
resistance particularly in waterhemp in
kosha it's no longer target side
resistance it's non-target size the the
target size has kind of gone away
so even when you have that trade-off
that is kind of negative there may be
another mechanism that can come along
and actually out compete it because now
it's it's more prolific it's you know
something with that mutation will be
more progeny than the first one
there are also the the i mentioned
another case of
target side resistance to dicamba
synthetic oxen and it's a mutation in
the dayground so it's uh you know a g
that glycine changes to an asparagine
gives resistance to the herbicide but
those plants are shorter they grow
slowly they make less seed
and so
um
anecdotally what people said like the
camber resistance this is in kosha has
been around since the 90s and there'd be
a field where the
grower manager would say hey you know we
the cam is not working so people go out
and check it out and okay yeah it's
definitely not working take some samples
go back to next year it's not there
anymore they can't find it so you even
have these dynamics of um
i think definitely how that fitness cost
goes out now there are other ones such
as uh
a great example some of the target site
mutations and the als gene acetyl
lactate synthase
they're those are non-competitive
inhibitor herbicides so the
a lot of herbicides do actually compete
with a substrate for binding but in the
case of this group the herbicides block
the kind of the channel and the protein
where the substrates go in so it can
look like anything it doesn't matter
what amino acids there just so long as
the substrate can still go through so
these mutations will just kind of block
that a little bit and the herbicide can
or such that the herbicide doesn't bind
and no longer blocks the entrance or it
doesn't even bind but it's shifted
and so we see for most of those there's
virtually no
trade-off at all for that resistance
allele
on the flip side also those tend to be
the much more common resistance
mutations i didn't have in this slide
deck but uh there's an example in france
where
they went to the herbarium samples for
the last 200 years of this grass weed
and they could find one collected in the
1700s that had one of these target site
mutations that probably doesn't have
much of a fitness cost but it was
present in in a sample in the herbarium
you know so 200 years before the
herbicide was discovered
out there
yeah so the quick question i know we
discussed it in our meeting but could
you share how easy it would be for even
like a place like cornell maybe our
plant diagnostic lab to have a facility
where we could detect say palmer
amaranth seeds
in a in a badge of seed yeah
we think that would involve or oh 100
you could do it so the question is um
so some use diagnostic assets whether
for species or for resistance you know
we're developing these with the standard
genotyping technologies that are used in
plant breeding and diagnostics so as
long as you can run a pcr and then for
that assay you need a a plate reader
that reads fluorescence that uses hex
and fan so either a real-time
thermocycler that's what we run it on or
you can run it on a regular thermocycler
and then it go to a plate reader um but
those are you know it's really high
throughput and
as long as you can extract dna and run
pcr you can you can run it
and uh
but yeah we're there you know we've
developed a palmer amaranth id we're
working on one for the kind of cloa
species it's similar in that complex
there's a lot of different ones
we have markers for myriaphalum some
aquatic weeds milfoil
and you can kind of go on any time and
that's a great research opportunity if
you have closely related species you
know maybe ones native ones introduced
or they're similar but
different in some way
you can definitely have more oh
one that
is also kind of a neat story phragmites
australis so this is a weed all around
the world
and it's um
they're native populations in this
continent and they're introduced ones
and so the native ones are actually
important for conservation you know we
want to keep them around
and they um you know have
ethnobotanical importance
and then you have the introduced ones
that are you know you don't want and
they're actually like in colorado they
introduced genotype as a listed noxious
species they have to control it and then
they have to preserve the native one and
you convert hardly tell them apart to
look at them so we did one of these
markers as well and uh so you can run it
yeah but as long as yeah i think for
sure your plan diagnostic clinic would
be able to run these
so we're
we're there great
thank you all very very much if you want
to hang around
thank you very much yeah
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu